tennyson in your article why nothing in
film has changed in a thousand years and
why anyone who says different is trying
to sell you something you mentioned in a
post that community and excellence at
your craft or all you need to worry
about and if the success or failure of
every project you've been in boiled down
to how that community interacted with
the larger whole yep absolutely I mean
are you asking what do I mean by that
yeah well I agree with myself okay good
one tennu yeah yeah you know I mean it
everything we've been talking about
today boils down to master your craft
and know your and love your audience and
mastering your craft is part of loving
your audience you know and at the same
time your audience is part of your craft
and and so make great movies tell great
stories do it very deliberately and make
sure that you are making the best
version of your story that you can never
cut the deal where you compromise on
that front never agree to it and learn
how to spot your own mistakes and your
own impulses towards self sabotage and
always always begin communication with
the audience or rep theatre succeeds on
its audience cultivation and you are a
rep theatre you have a global audience
that you have access to every day they
want to be involved they want to know
what you're doing it's why they
participate don't just wait for them to
show up at the box office every day make
them a priority and learn how to love
them learn what's great about them and
that will inform what stories you want
to tell and it'll make you want to do
better
you